the show. Our first guest, Michael
Valtos.
Hello, Michael.
Hi, good morning, Anna. How are you?
Hopefully, um you can see my screen
okay.
The screen looks good to me. You have 45
minutes.
Okay, great. Thank you, Anna. So, hey
everybody, it's Mike. It's April 15th.
It's tax day in the US, even though um I
think they extended it out to um May,
another month
for everybody, which is always nice. You
know, it's always
um the time after
tax day in the US, April 15th, is always
uh we always get a nice little rally,
but it just seems like this rally has
been going on and on um
since beginning of the year. And
you know, people ask me, you know, how
can I use order flow to see what's
happening in the market, you know,
because sometimes they they they they
can't make heads or tails of this rally,
because it just you know, everything
says, you know, the market shouldn't go
up, but it keeps going up. And I want to
show you today how you could use order
flow to see things in the market rally
that other people can't see. So,
oops.
What you're going to learn today is why
order flow is so valuable to a trader.
I'm going to show you how to put the
pieces of order flow together, and I'm
going to show you how to recognize
actionable order flow. And what do I
mean mean by actionable order flow is
trades that you can take based on the
order flow. You know, the way I like to
describe order flow, it's it's almost
like reading a book, you know, and
you know, the market
is a story that's that's constantly
being updated, and um you know, new
chapters being put on, and it's just
fascinating how you can read what's
happening in the market based on the
trading that's happening out there.
So, those of you that are new to who I
am, my name is Michael Valtos, and I'm
the owner of trader
at orderflows.com. I started this in in
2015 after I left uh JP Morgan. Um spent
eight years at JP Morgan as vice
president of futures trading.
You know, on the trading desk actually
trading not sitting in an office looking
at spreadsheets and
you know, saying oh, you know, the risk
is too much or anything. No, you know,
actually on the desk pounding out trades
from 6:00 in the morning when
the markets opened until 5:00 p.m. at
night. I was based in Singapore. So that
was the Globex reopen
you know, after the main session closed
cuz we're in Asia and up until
you know, basically almost you know,
mid-morning in London time. Prior to
that I was with Cargill the big
commodity trading firm in the US.
You know, it's probably this I think
it's the second largest privately held
company in the United States. You know,
they got over 130,000 employees all
around the world and they trade
everything you can imagine. Before that
I was with Commerzbank in Chicago. I was
their licensed Eurex trader for 3 years.
I spent 2 years prior to that at EDF Man
also the big English trading company has
been around since the 1700s.
And I started on the CME floor with Dean
Witter
and I left the trading floor when
electronic trading started taking hold
back in the early 90s. You know, that
was probably one of the
the best decisions
that I made in my career. You know, it's
cuz I realized you know, what you know,
I was in my early 20s and computerized
trading was just starting to take off
and I realized you know, what that's
where I want to be and you know, it was
just
amazing watching the growth and
unfortunately watching the floors close
down. And you know, one of the reasons
why I like doing presentations like this
is because you know, I was able to get
started
on the trading floor. You know, back
when there were trading floors, you
could go down to the trading floor and
literally stand outside the front door
ask somebody
for a job. You know, I knew a person
that was shining shoes outside the
exchange and eventually they ended up
landing a job because they they the
shoes for
one of the traders and said yeah, sure,
I'll give you a job." You know, now you
don't have that entry. Right? Now, you
know, if you want to get a job at a bank
or a hedge fund or a trading firm, you
know, you have to have
graduate from a certain school with a
certain background and all that, you
know, whereas before it was the barrier
to entry was so low that, you know,
almost literally anybody could go get
started. And
you know, so I learned a lot in, you
know, my over 20 years of institutional
trading and, you know, I like to share
it with people because they just don't
have
that access to knowledge. Now, after I
left JP Morgan, I left it in 2015 uh
2013 and
I I was trading for myself using order
flow, using everything that I've learned
about order flow over the years.
And there was software out there which
was just pretty basic order flow
analysis software and I realized, you
know what? The computer can do a lot
more for you. It can analyze the
information that you're seeing.
And so
around 2014, I started working with a
programmer to create my own software,
right? Basically take the order flow
software that was out there and improve
it, right? Just like Steve Jobs didn't
invent
the mobile phone, right? When he created
the iPhone, he took the existing
technology out there and made it better.
And my software
runs on NinjaTrader 8. It's called the
Order Flows Trader and it's a volume
footprint chart with 17 pre-programmed
order flow indicators or tools which I I
do show you some in this presentation.
And the reason I just talk about this
really briefly is because, you know, the
charts that I use in this presentation
are generated from that software. Now,
I also wrote a book on trading order
flow. You know, I like to say I
literally wrote the book on it, but
there had been no
no good information for traders out
there. So, you know, in 2015, I also,
you know, I was trading and I started
writing my book on order flow. And if
you stick until the end, I'm going to
show you how to get it for free. Okay,
it's 150 pages. All you got to do is
just uh go to the link that I'm going to
give you. And then you you can download
it to your iPhone, you know, your your
tablet or whatever, your computer, and
print it up if you like. Or you just
read it from your iPhone. Now, before I
begin, you know, just a brief
disclaimer, do understand that trading
involves risk, and only risk capital
should be used for trading. Okay?
So, let me ask you, you know, most of
us, you know, we're we're familiar with
looking at a normal candlestick chart,
okay? And when we look at a normal bar
chart or candlestick chart, all we're
really doing
is one thing. We are following price,
okay? And, you know, the the way I kind
of describe it sometimes is it's a bit
like going up and down a ladder, right?
Cuz, you know, candlestick charts
are a little bit different than a normal
bar open high low close chart in that
they, you know, have colors, you know,
green for a bar that closed up, red for
a bar that closed down. And it it's a
bit like going up and down a ladder,
right? The market goes up, then you get
some red candles, it looks like it's
about to go down, but it goes back up.
But really, what it's more like is like
this child's game, called, you know,
shoots and ladder or Candy Land, where
you're going up, you know, you roll the
dice, move a certain amount forward,
then, oh, you got to go back down. You
know, and the market's a bit like that.
And if you're just watching price,
right? You're just seeing where the
market was, right? It's not giving you
much clue into where the market can
potentially go, right? And as a trader,
that's what we want to know, you know,
which is the What is the path of least
resistance? Where is the market going to
be going?
Now, where does the information from the
bar chart comes from? Well,
it comes from the time and sales, right?
What actually traded in the market,
right? The market's traded in a two-way
auction. There's a bid, and there's an
offer. Now,
the time and sales just reports
what traded, you know, at what time it
traded, the price it traded, and the
quantity it traded, but the problem is
now with the markets move very fast,
very quickly with a lot of volume,
you know, this is just literally
2 seconds, right? And there's probably
more information in here and you can see
there's a lot of trades going through.
There's a lot of one lots, two lot, you
know, one here's six, here's
five, a lot of ones, and you see
um, you know, orange or red prices, you
see green prices, you know, and
a lot of people can't make heads or
tails of it, but all this information
that you're seeing here is what goes on
a bar chart, but there's a lot of
information here.
Right? You have most people think that,
you know, for every buyer there's a
seller and and there is, okay? But
there's different types of buyers and
sellers. You have aggressive buyers, you
have aggressive sellers. You have
passive buyers, you have passive
sellers.
The way to think of it is aggressive
sellers sell to the passive buyers.
Aggressive buyers buy from the passive
sellers. And the best way to think of it
is when you're trying to buy a house
right now, right? The market is crazy,
pretty much everywhere in the world for
buying a house, and you know that if
you're trying to buy a house, you got to
be very aggressive, right? Say the house
is listed at $500,000, you know, you got
to just, you know, if you like it, you
just got to buy it, right? And sometimes
you got to offer even more money, right?
You are being the aggressive buyer,
right? The seller is happy to sell it at
500,000. Now,
say this property market crashes, right?
And all of a sudden it becomes a buyer's
market, it's the sellers who will be
aggressive, right? So, your your house,
if you're the seller, right? You're
trying to sell this house for half a
million dollars, all of a sudden now the
market conditions have changed.
There's no buyers. So, what do you have
to do? As a seller, you have to be
aggressive. You have to find where
there's a bid in the market, you know,
maybe the market, maybe there's a buyer
there at 450,000. Okay, you're happy
you'll sell it to him. You're going to
be the aggressive seller because you're
selling to the buyer that's like, yeah,
I like this house, but there's so many
houses now on the market, you know, I'll
I'll pay you 450 for that. Okay, they'll
sell it to you there, right? Whereas now
it's it's we're in a
in a seller's market where it's the
buyers who are aggressive.
Now,
about you know, when electronic trading
really started
um taking hold back in the early 2000s,
even though electronic trading has been
around since the '90s,
the depth of market has become
a tool that a lot of traders started
looking at. And again, you know, the
market's traded in a two-way auction.
So, what you have is
volume on the bid. Now, you can look at
volume on the offer as well, as opposed
to just looking at the volume that
traded. And so, you get an idea of where
the passive sellers are, where the
passive buyers are, right? Where people
are happy to buy below the market or
sell above the market. And again,
remember, aggressive sellers sell to the
passive buyers.
Aggressive buyers buy from the passive
sellers. That's what makes the market go
up or down is what the aggressive
traders are doing. Are there aggressive
sellers or are there aggressive buyers?
People that are clearing out the
liquidity in the market, right?
Liquidity
is, you know, the the resting orders in
the market, right? Either above the
offer or below the bid. Okay? But again,
reading a depth of market, just like
reading a time and sales,
is very difficult for a lot of traders,
right? I mean, it's easy to look at a
video and see somebody, oh, yeah, you
know, I'm going to I'm going to sell
here, buy, you know, I'm going to buy
here, you know, there's a big bid here,
you know, I'm going to do this. But it
takes many, many, many years of
experience and
many, many years of trial and error as a
trader to really get it going. You know,
honestly, about
5, 10 years ago, the markets were a lot
calmer. You know, when we're trading
1,200 in the S&Ps, we would have a
10-point range for the day. Now, we're
getting 40, 50-point ranges. You you
we're getting bars that, you know, price
ranges in 1 minute of 10 handles. You
know, that's
in the past that was one whole day. Now,
if you're trying to read a dome, the
market's moving too fast
that you you can't make good
trading decisions consistently. You
know, you could you could find some good
trades, but being consistent is sort of
the holy grail in trading. You know,
people always say, "What's the holy
grail in trading?" It's about being
consistent as a trader.
But, interpreting what you see in the
dome and time and sales, it's it's like
being in the water and being thrown a
life preserver, right? The life
preserver is your dome or your time and
sales, but you're just you're going to
you're going to sink. You're going to
drown. You still need more help because
it's just moving too fast, right? It's
not like the old days where things
would, you know, imagine trading in the
night session now is what it was like
trading in the day session 5 years ago,
10 years ago. It was a lot
calmer in terms of market activity
um and and price movements.
So,
what somebody developed, I didn't
develop this, is the volume footprint
chart, okay, which takes the information
you're seeing from the time and sales
and puts it into an easy-to-read chart.
And it's from that footprint chart
that you can make good trading
decisions. And there's three main points
of order flow, delta, point of control,
and imbalance. So,
what makes the footprint chart much
different than say your normal bar chart
is you can see the volume. You can see
the volume traded on the bid.
You can see the volume traded on the
offer. You can see where the most volume
in a bar traded.
You can see how the market
reacted at the extremes, at the high or
the low of the bar, at the high or the
low of a swing, at the higher or low of
the day, right? And that's very valuable
information as a trader.
Now, I'll just briefly explain what the
three pieces are. Delta is the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers, right? And it's
important to know so that you know who
is dominating the current market as
shown in the bar, right? It's It's
people get
so complacent looking at a bar chart and
say, "Well, the candle is green, so
yeah, I know buyers are in control. We
closed higher."
Yes, that's a basic way to look at it,
but when you start looking at the
volume, you can interpret it um
in a few different ways to give you show
you times where it's actually very
strong or if market is weak.
So, volume the delta is the difference
between the volume traded on the
offer versus volume traded on the bid,
okay? And delta in most software on
footprint charts will appear at the
bottom. So,
you know, you'll have negative or
positive, and sometimes it'll be zero.
Just just coincidence, but generally red
bars will have negative delta, and green
bars will have positive delta, but
you're going to see bars like this. This
is a green candle.
But, it's got big negative delta, okay?
And I'm going to talk about that a bit
later.
Now, point of control
is the second part of order flow that's
important is the price level
in the bar with the most volume. Now,
there's no mathematical fancy formula to
determine it. It's just simple
arithmetic. You take the volume traded
on the bid at a price and the volume
traded at the offer on a price, and if
at that price in the bar is the most
volume, that's your point of control.
Every bar has a point of control.
Okay, I I just highlighted a few here,
right? You can see on this red bar
it's highlighted with like this gray
rectangle around it. Every bar has one,
right? Whether it's a red bar um
a green bar or even a doji bar, right? A
bar that opens and closes at the same
price. Now, I've highlighted this golden
one
because this is one of the things that I
want talk about is
having software that's going to do do
some of the order flow analysis for you
and tell you, "Hey, you know what? This
point of control matters. This point of
control is support." Or in another case,
this point of control is resistance,
right? So, you know, that's how order
flow is going to help you in terms of
analyzing volume. So, now you have
volume in the bar, where the most volume
is. You have volume in terms of the
difference between the aggressive buyers
and the aggressive sellers in the bar.
That's the delta.
Now,
the third part is imbalances. Market
imbalances occur when there are more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers, or vice versa, more aggressive
sellers and buyers in the two-way
auction. Remember, a market is trades in
a two-way auction. It's 26 bid at 27,
right? And how the market reacts when it
trades 26 versus it trades 27, can give
you clues, right? The volume that's
traded, if you have an imbalance, you
could have a buy imbalance, which would
occur when there's at least four times
as many traders buying the offer than
traders selling the bid. A sell
imbalance is the opposite. It's when
there are at least four times as many
traders selling the bid than traders
buying the offer, right? And think of an
imbalance like this, right? You got the
elephant pushing the car, right? You're
driving down the road in Africa and
you're in your little car, rental car,
and there's an elephant in there. You
think, "Ah, I could take him. You know,
I'm in a car." Well, the elephant just
comes right up and pushes you out of the
way. That's an imbalance. Like, the
elephant is much stronger and much
bigger than you, okay? And you're going
to lose. So,
in a bar, right? On the footprint chart,
there's
red numbers, there's blue numbers, and
there's black numbers. Your normal
trading that's happening is a black
number in the bar. There's nothing
special, right? That's just the normal
trade. But, you're going to see in a bar
red numbers, right? You see 11 against
1, 19 against one, 10 against three, um
14 against zero, you know, four against
22. These are selling imbalances, all
right? Just as you have blue numbers,
which are buying imbalances, three
against 88, um one against five, 17
against 60, 12 against 40, nine against
39. These are buying imbalances, and
what it's telling you in the two-way
auction, if you have a buying imbalance,
there was more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling, right? When the
market was 70 bid at 71,
you had
12 aggressive sellers versus 40
aggressive buyers, okay? So, you have an
imbalance at that price in that bar,
okay?
And so, now you're taking the volume
that's traded in the two-way auction,
and you're able to
come away with something that you can
use
to trade around, right? Because you know
that if you have aggressive buying, what
do you think the market's going to do?
Generally, it's going to go up. If you
have aggressive selling, generally, what
the market
the way it's the direction it's leaning
towards is
coming off, okay?
Now, generally, like I said, as the
market rises, you see buying imbalances.
Aggressive buyers are lifting the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer, right? They're they're cleaning
off the whatever's on the offer, and
they're buying the next one, right? Just
think of it as um
you know, when you know, at Christmas
time, when there's the hot toy, all
right? That that every kid needs,
you know, and you go around, you're
looking for it, and prices just keep
going up. It's because everybody is
buying that supply, and the sellers know
that they could sell it for higher,
right? So, they mark the price up
because people the demand is there, they
will buy it. Whereas,
if the market is falling, you generally
see selling imbalances, right?
Aggressive sellers are selling into the
best bid and looking for the next best
bid to sell into. Why? It's because now
there's a lot of supply
in the market, right? So, they're
they're happy to keep selling it as the
price goes down at lower prices cuz they
have a lot of supply they have to get
rid of. So,
what what's the whole point of order
flow? Well, it asked the answers the
question
what is the market doing? Right? That
That's the question that you always want
to be asking as a trader, what is the
market doing? And again, most traders
look at a chart
and try to figure out what the market is
doing and where it's going based on
incomplete information, right? They're
just looking at price. Right? They're
not looking at the volume. And yeah,
this was crude just yesterday, right?
Remember crude had a nice rally
yesterday, but you know, it was sort of
midway up in this rally, the market hit
the high, came off, and then just sort
of went sideways. Well, you know, as a
trader,
you want to know, okay, well, why is the
market pausing in here? What What's
causing it to stop in here? You know,
people can say, well, I'm looking at the
candles, you know, you got small ranges,
you got a doji here.
Um you know, it's this tested this. But,
you know, as a trader, as it's
happening, you want to know why it's
acting like that.
Right? This was This is the that area I
just showed you on the previous chart. I
just I took it out of
show you on a on a bigger scale is
volume. Right?
Volume is telling you
that there's support here, okay? And
that's really what you want to know as a
trader. Where are areas where the market
can stop?
Where are areas the market can trade
through?
Volume, right? Well, the price stopped
here because of volume, okay? Obviously,
you have this point of control right
down here. You can see the volume, 196.
Right? And people say, well, you have
negative delta, isn't that bearish?
Well,
technically, it is, but what you have,
remember,
you have an selling imbalance here, 196
against 41. You know, Mike, you just
said, if you have aggressive selling,
the market should go down, but actually,
you it a step further. That's why I
said, think outside the box. Don't think
in
um terms of well, I got aggressive
selling, it should be short. What you
have here is you have support in the
market. You have a buyer that's
absorbing all the aggressive selling
that's going on down here. It's causing
the most volume in the bar at this at
the low of the bar. You have 196 against
41. So, you had very strong selling, but
there's a buyer here. Yeah, sure. You
want to sell some more? I'll buy it.
Right? Market started to go up a little
bit, just went sideways, came back down.
That buyer is still there. Now, you see
an imbalance of 63 against 21.
Right? Now, the thing with imbalances,
the industry standard, right? What most
people traders use is 4:1, but a lot of
traders use 3:1 um and 5:1. But again,
you know, I said 4:1, but
you know, depending on the market that
you're looking at, you can adjust it,
right? It's not set in stone that oh, it
has to be 4:1. You know, I use 3:1 a lot
of times. I know a lot of other traders
that use 3:1. I know traders that use um
almost 10:1. They use 987 for some
reason cuz I think it's a fib number,
but you know, 10:1 basically, you could
look for as well. You know, there's
different ways
of using imbalances to look for things.
I mean, if you have an imbalance that's
10:1, right? 10 buyers
to one seller. What do you think the
market's telling you? You know, it's
telling you it's pretty strong in that
direction, okay? So, you want to know
those.
But what's happened here? The market is
stopping because of the volume, right?
And as a trader, that's valuable
information, right? Look at how this
market reacted, you know, from the 70
area all the way up into the 30s. Now
again, you know, I know a lot of traders
will will trade this like, well, you got
this double top, I'm waiting for it to
break out before I get long. You buy
that breakout, then it sells off another
20 point, another 25 um
ticks before it goes back up, right? But
if you're trading down here and you can
see the volume that's happening that's
stopping this move, you could be getting
long down here at 70
for the move back up, you know, back up
to 6300.
You know, it came back down. It's
holding these levels, okay? Maybe you
put some more on. And it goes up, rather
than you know, what most traders will
trade it is all awaiting for this
breakout, you know, take out the
previous high. You can know what's
happening down in here as soon as it
happens.
Okay? But, again, it's not just about
looking for areas of heavy volume. You
can analyze volume in relation to how
it's traded. That's where the order flow
comes in. The delta, the point of
control, and imbalances. I mean, it's
one thing to see, oh yeah, there's heavy
volume at this price. You know, that's
that's important. I can trade around
that. But,
you don't always get those crystal clear
examples, right? That's why you got to
look at the order flow.
Right? And here's the market. This was
E-minis yesterday, right? Market selling
off nicely, right? You seen a lot of
selling imbalances on the way down.
That's what you like to see.
Okay? You seen the negative deltas for
the most part, minus 1200, minus 1500,
minus
3500. You mean, you do have some little
bit of buying that comes in once in a
while, 400, 472.
But, then as it comes into this bottom
down in in here, what do you start to
see? Well, you start to see
several bars with buying imbalances.
Now, there was
some buying imbalances here, okay? I
mean, this market looked like it was
getting primed to rally in here, right?
But, you're not getting the follow
through. Right? You got a bar with one,
two, three imbalances, buying
imbalances, which is good. But, then
this next bar, there's no follow
through.
Right? And obviously, you got the
negative delta. But, as you're looking
in here, right? As you're coming down,
very strong negative delta, 1200, 1500,
3000.
All of a sudden, it gets very small,
minus 118, minus 500, minus 257.
Now you got strong positive delta, 400.
A small delta, 135. Then a nice strong
positive delta, 1271, right? And here
you got 1 2 3 4 5 6 buying imbalances.
Okay? In this bar, so that's that's
good, right? You're seeing the
aggressive buying coming in. You're
seeing the imbalances come in. You're
seeing points of control
go higher, basically, you know,
from the low here. You know, maybe this
one's more or less the same. It's one
tick lower. Higher point of control. So
basically you got 1 2 3 higher points of
control, four here. And the market
putting a little bit of a rally. Right?
That's how you could use the different
pieces of volume, right? You don't have
to analyze necessarily every single
print that goes through. Oh, you know,
it traded
No, you could just look at, okay, what's
the delta doing? Is it growing? Is it
getting bigger positive or bigger
negative? You know, as we're coming
down,
you know, eventually
lows are going to be made. And as you
come into lows, you start to see the
selling weakening in terms of the
negative delta, right? It tends to get
smaller. Minus 118, minus 585, minus
257. Then it starts turning positive.
For a market to start rallying, you're
going to need to string together bars
with strong positive delta, which you're
starting to see here. 400, 1200, 600.
Okay? And obviously the points of
control are going higher. On moves down,
points of controls generally go lower.
Again, this was also yesterday in the
E-minis, right? What does order flow
tell us? Well, in this blue box, you
know, it's kind of mixed to a little bit
bullish, right? In the red box, it's
definitely bearish. Okay? You know, in
here, you know,
it's mostly going sideways, honestly.
You're seeing some buying imbalances.
Delta's kind of mixed. You're seeing
some positive, some negative.
Um but you see, you know, some bars with
some nice positive deltas. Again, points
of controls are sort of lining up almost
at identical levels. Here, you got three
at the same level. Here, you've got two
back-to-back, two back-to-back. And
again, it's just sort of choppy. But
then you get up in here, right? You can
see delta turns negative, 122. But then
minus 22, which is small. 16, which is
small. I sort of treat those as neutral.
Uh, then minus 300, right? Minus 700,
okay? And what do you see now? You're
seeing a lot of selling imbalances.
You're seeing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
imbalances, selling imbalances, right?
Before you even get to this red bar with
three more selling imbalances, right?
With the nice big negative delta. So, if
you're looking at these this group of
five bars, you know, what you're seeing
in here is kind of mixed to it, maybe a
little bit bullish. But in here, it's
definitely bearish, right? What do you
think the market's going to do? You
know, someone's going to say, "Hey, hey,
you got to take a trade." Well, you got
to get short, right? You're not going to
get long. You're not going to be looking
to buy in here with all the selling
coming in. And that's where the volume
is going to help you, right? Volume in
the difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in the delta,
imbalances, in the two-way auction, and
points of control. Because as the market
goes down,
it's looking for, you know, imagine,
right? There's a lot of supply coming
into the market. Traders are looking for
an area
that they can move a lot of supply. And
if the market is getting
overwhelmed with supply,
it's going to be trading lower, right?
The volume is going to be trading lower.
They're happy to sell it at lower prices
cuz they have a lot of volume. That's
why points of controls go down.
Let's take a look at gold. Similar
story, right? On the way down, a lot of
selling, right? You see the aggressive,
um, sellers in the bars with the many
imbalances, right?
Then you sort of get down into the low,
then you seeing the aggressive buying
starting to pick up, right? You see 82,
120, 48, you know, 21, then 1, 91, 159.
Right? You got this nice move up and on
this nice move up, you're seeing higher
points of controls for the most part.
You know, here you got one that's one
tick lower, this one's one tick lower,
but then it jumps back up, higher point
of control, higher point of control.
Here, this bar has got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
imbalances. This bar has got four buying
imbalances, right? You can see the
delta's just getting stronger. Right?
It's gone from kind of mixed in here, 48
21 and 1 to positive 91, positive 159,
and you get this nice move from, you
know, the 35 and 1/2 area all the way up
to the 38 and 1/2 area in basically 7 8
minutes, right? The market is telling
you, "Hey, you know what? This low is
holding. Aggressive buyers are coming
into the market." Right? That's how
order flow
is going to help you as a trader.
So, let me ask you, how many times have
you taken a trade and immediately went
against you, right? It happens all of
us, right? It happens to me.
What you do next can determine if you're
going to be successful or not in the
trade, and that's where order flow is
going to help you. You know, do you let
a trade stop you out or are you willing
to get out of a bad trade early, you
know, at a level with a smaller loss?
And that's where reading the order flow
helps you as a trader. It can tell you,
"Hey, you know what? Conditions have
changed in the market. You you might
want to think about getting out." Right?
You don't have to wait till the market
stops you out. If the market is telling
you, "Hey, you know what? You're long,
but we're seeing selling coming in, you
you got to get out." Right? You don't
need to wait for it to stop you out. Oh,
there's a lot of selling coming in. I
better get out now, right? That's where
the order flow is going to help you,
right? It's that market-generated
information
is based on the volume the market traded
on the bid and the volume traded on the
offer at a price. It's going to tell you
when the market conditions change,
right? So, imagine, right? You're in a
short position, right? Market is making
new lows. Yay, happy days, right? You're
happy. You know, you're short. Oh, then
you get that big bar down, that
beautiful bar down. You know, it just
drops from 40 down to 30, you know, 36.
And then it starts putting in these new
lows. But then as it gets down here, you
got to be asking, okay, is this the end
of that move? So, you start looking at
these bars, all right? And you see a
higher point of control. Okay, that's
bullish. You're starting to see buying
imbalances, right? You don't see the
selling imbalances anymore, right? That
you saw on this on these big pushes down
here, right? With all the red in the
bar. You just seeing buying imbalances.
Now, you don't have to sit here and
analyze, well, it's three against 17. Um
it's 11 against 52. It's three against
18. Now, you just say, okay, I got a
buying imbalance here. I've got four
buying imbalances here. I've got five
buying imbalances in this bar. Right?
You see the delta. Okay, what's delta
doing? Well, we're at the low. You've
got positive delta. What do you think
the market's telling you? Right? That's
a divergence in the order flow.
If you make a new or equal low, and
you've got positive delta, well, all of
a sudden now you got buyers coming into
the market, right? That's important
information, all right? That people
aren't picking up because they're not
looking at the order flow.
You know,
that's what markets do, right? They They
They go to find buyers. They go to find
sellers, right? The markets go up or
down looking for buyers, looking for
sellers. You're at your low of the day,
and all of a sudden buyers are coming
in, and they're coming in pretty
aggressive. What do you think the
market's going to do? Going to go higher
or go lower? Well, chances are it's
going to go higher. So, you start
putting these pieces together. Points of
controls are moving up. Aggressive
buying coming in in terms of imbalance.
Deltas are positive. So, it's telling me
overall, these bars are bullish, right?
And then the market
makes a nice move higher. All right?
MNQ, right? This is a 20 range chart.
Again, you got to be looking at what's
happening in terms of imbalances, delta,
point of control. And it And order flow
is not about analyzing every single tick
that goes through. Some people like to.
I don't. Yeah, I don't think you need
to.
But as this market's going down, right?
You're seeing the aggressive selling,
right? You're seeing the negative
deltas. You're seeing the lower points
of control. You're seeing the selling
imbalances. Then the market just sort of
goes sideways in here. Okay? But then it
starts to rip up, right? As it rips up,
you're getting the positive deltas. You
can see it down here on the bottom.
You know, the 213980.
You're seeing the buying imbalances
coming in, right? You're seeing the
higher points of control as you're
finally starting to put in a move up.
One, two, three consecutive higher
points of control just as on this move
down, you see consecutive points of
control going down. You know, one, two,
three, four, five lower points of
control. In here, it's kind of mixed.
But then
the direction at this point is clear,
right? That it's going up.
And again, you know, like I said
earlier, you know, order flow is like
reading a book, right? Understanding
what's happening in the market, right?
This is beautiful from the E-minis the
other day.
It came up to the high here at 4119 and
a quarter, then we sold off almost
immediately. But as you're going up,
what do you see? Okay? What you see,
higher points of control, which is what
you like to see. Okay?
You're seeing some buying imbalances on
the way up. That's what you like to see.
But you're seeing
negative delta. Okay. You know, it's
kind of mixed. 2161 minus 77. You got a
nice bar here with nice positive delta,
722.
But then it just sort of spins around up
here. Yeah, at the high of the day, you
got negative delta. The next bar,
also negative delta.
But you're seeing all of a sudden, now
you're seeing
one, two, three, four, five selling
imbalances, right? That's not good.
Right? You're seeing aggressive selling
up here near the high.
What do you think the market's going to
do? Well, chances are it's going to fall
over, right? And it just goes sideways,
points of control sort of migrate a bit
higher, you know, the kind of then they
get mixed in here, but then they drop
off
lower, lower, lower. You're seeing the
aggressive selling coming in in the
imbalances. You're seeing just negative
delta, so you know, you're up here at
your high of the day
and you're seeing
mostly every bar up here, right up at
the high of the day, it's got negative
delta. What do you think is happening?
You got aggressive selling at the high
of the day. Do you think the market's
going to go higher? You know, it might
later and it
but for now, the direction is going to
be down. That's the way you got to
position yourself. So, remember, right?
For a market to move in the direction
you expect it to, there needs to be
follow through order flow. If there's no
follow through order flow,
what reason is there for the market to
move, right? Your super duper indicator
is not what makes the market move.
Markets move because the actual buying
and selling taking place in the market,
right? Order flow analysis provides the
trader that information they need to get
that edge over other traders. That's
what everyone always says, you know, any
book on trading, any video, you got to
have an edge, you got to have an edge,
but they don't really tell you how to
find that edge. Order flow gives you
that edge. It allows you to see and
understand what's happening in the
market that other traders don't see.
And that's one of the reasons why, you
know, I designed the Order Flows Trader,
you know, 6 years ago is because I
realized I could have the software do a
lot of the analysis for me, right? I
want to know where there's divergence,
you know, when we're at the high of the
day and there's aggressive selling
coming in. I I want to know where
there's market weakness in terms of
looking at the delta, right? That's what
these blue arrows are. It's telling me
there's market weakness, right? I want
to know which points of controls are
going to be bearish, right? Like these
two purple ones, right? That's telling
me these points of controls matter and
they're bearish, right? That's
resistance. Support in point of control,
that's this blue point of control. You
know, that's that's where having good
software helps you as a trader, helps
you get an edge over other traders that
aren't looking
at volume, let alone looking at order
flow all together, right? They don't
know that there's, you know, at this
high of the day that there's aggressive
selling coming in in terms of the delta.
They don't know that there's, based on
the volume in the bar, that there's
resistance up here. I mean, why does
this market trade right up to this
price, right? One tick below the point
of control is because there's resistance
based on what traded here, right? It's
It's important to know that information
as a trader.
Right? And again, you know,
let the software help you as a trader,
right? Let it determine, "Hey, you know
what? There's market weakness down here
at this swing low."
So, you could position yourself that if
you start seeing other things like
um aggressive buying coming in in terms
of imbalance, you could take the market
back up, right? That's what That's the
information that order flow is going to
give you to give you an edge. Now,
when I first released the Order Flow
Suite Trader back in 2015, one of the
things that I put in it was
what I call ratios, order flow ratios.
That's why you see on some bars
um blue numbers above a bar or black
numbers above or below a bar.
And what it means, if it's a black
number, it's just basically your order
flow that's
your normal order flow. But, when
there's a blue number, right? That's
telling you there's a ratio in the order
flow by analyzing the volume in there.
And
depending on where it comes in,
it's going to tell you there's either
price exhaustion
or price defense, right? Stopping
volume, right? So,
that's why you often see, you know,
markets stop and reverse or stop and go
sideways at areas where there's ratios.
And one of my bread and butter trades is
a divergence and a ratio like you have
right here, right? Your high of the day
and you have a ratio, right? 45. First
time you had your divergence, that's
this red here, right? You got the
negative delta 162 at the high of the
day. Here you got negative delta 800 at
your high of the day, but this time
based on the order flow in this bar is
telling you there's price exhaustion the
second time we hit it. There wasn't the
first time.
But this is a trade that, you know, it's
sort of, you know, my one of always been
one of my bread and butter trades.
Happens all the time in pretty much
every market. I'll say all the time, but
you know, most days it will happen at
least once or twice.
So it's a great trade to look at. And
it's funny because when I released my
software by within 6 months a lot of
other software started putting these
ratios in. But you know what? It's
it they never understood how to use it.
So it's like what's the point of having
tools when you don't know how to use it,
right? I mean
I use NinjaTrader, right? NinjaTrader's
got 3-400 separate indicators in there
that I don't use cuz first of all, I
don't understand a lot of these things.
You know, what's the point of having
tools that you're not going to use?
That's why everything that's in the
order flow indicator is tools for
traders to use, right? Because it's
designed by a trader that's trading it,
right? Here's another example,
divergence and a ratio.
Right? A nice move down to where?
Support. Market generated support. And
it moved up to where? Market generated
resistance.
All right? That's these points of
control.
And again, you know, even at the high of
the day knowing that there's
three selling imbalances in this bar,
you got your high of the day. Look, you
got aggressive selling coming in. Again,
that's more information that as a trader
you can use. So hopefully you can see
how powerful order flow analysis is,
right? You don't need to overcomplicate
trading. Just trade what's happening
right in front of you. So if you found
this helpful, you're going to like this
package that I have developed for you,
right? If you really want to add order
flow analysis to your trading, you know,
raise your hand. Now there's two ways
you can do it, right? You could spend a
year looking at the screen trying to
figure out order flow, waste a year of
your life, and more money trading. And
when I ask you, you know, next year,
when you come to one of my
presentations, how's your trading going?
You just give me the thumbs up, you
know, you're still alive, but you're
suffering. Or the easy way. Get the
education and software from a trader who
has
successfully traded order flow at the
highest level for decades. You're going
to skip the massive trading losses, skip
the wasted time. So, you get the order
flows trader
software for NinjaTrader 8. Again, it's
the software that has 17 pre-programmed
order flow indicators. I talked about
two of them here.
And you're going to Normally, I sell
this for $899, right? But
you're not going to pay that today. Now,
I realize having order flow software is
one thing, right? You got to know how to
use it. So, I give you a lot of
education. Okay? So, each week I do a
live group training session just for
users of the software. If you can't
attend, you can watch the recordings.
There's over 116 videos. Um so, it's
been going on for over 2 years. And
again, other people sell you software
for four figures, and then charge you
extra to learn how to use it, right?
This is weekly training. You can come
in, you can ask your questions. Um I do
it all for free because I want you to
get up to speed on trading order flow.
And I'll also give you access to my
order flow trading course, which
normally sells for $297. There's 20
lessons. It's 15 hours of video
instruction.
But also, right? For those that really
want to jump in, dive deeper, I've got
the order flow inner circle video
series.
And normally, I sell this access to the
just these videos is for $497. There's
56 videos on advanced order flow
um analysis, nuances, and tips, right?
So, you can get all that for free,
right? So, you start adding all that
together,
right? The software, the training, the
inner circle video series. I don't even
put a price on the live group training
because I think it's I don't want to say
priceless, but you know,
it's it's a way to improve your trading,
right? That not a lot of people have
access to, right? You can come in there,
you can ask me any of your questions and
I'll do my best to answer them. Um you
know, that's really $1,600. You're not
going to pay that.
And because of Investors Expo, I got
even a special bonus for you. I'll give
you access to my order flow playbook,
which is
um additional training and there's I
think 10 or 11 additional trade setups
that you can look for in the order flow
and give you that for free.
So, that's almost $2,000 worth of
software and training, right?
So, you know, what other people are
saying is, you know, the order flow
trader software is very helpful. They
can see who's in control of the market,
right? So,
it's time to think about your success,
right? But you got to plan it to get
there, okay? You can't You're not going
to get anywhere without planning it. So,
for a one-time payment of $749, you're
going to get access to the software and
all the training. There's no more fees
you have to pay me. That's it, right?
Some people like to charge you a
recurring fee, $100, $200 a month and
then you can never cancel it. No, it's
just a one-time payment, right? So, you
go to orderflows.com/oft3
and I'll just put the link in the box
there for you guys. And
you know, it's just you go to this page.
You scroll down this page right here,
right? You just scroll down on the side.
Takes you down here. You click on that
button. Now, there's a bunch of videos
and and more
charts you could look at to show you how
to use the software. You just click on
this button to buy now, right? Takes you
to PayPal. I don't get your credit card
information. I don't want it. It's all
handled through PayPal.
And you just That's it. Simple, right?
Then within
um usually a couple hours cuz you know,
things has to get processed and and user
IDs and logins have to and licenses have
to be created. Um you'll you'll get it
in your email, right? The email that you
use with PayPal. Now, for those that
stuck around and want a copy of my book,
just go to orderflows.com/book.html.
You just got to enter your
first name, last name, and the email.
Click submit and then it takes you
directly to the page you can download it
from. Okay? So,
the main point is you got to get
started, right? It's we're a year from
basically when the world locked down.
You know, you should ask yourself where
you are now versus where you were a year
ago. Are you where you want to be in
terms of trading and you know, being
able to become a
full-time trader or even someone that's
doing it part-time and is consistent,
right? That's that's what you have to
do. Right? You got to take action. You
got to act now.
So, anyway, Anna, um
I I don't have time for questions, but
if anybody's got a question, they can
just shoot me an email. It's um my
contact's on my website. It's just
mike@orderflows.com.
But again, all the links are in the
chat, you know, for downloading the
book, it's orderflows.com/book.html.
And the software, just go to
orderflows.com/
oft3, oft3, cuz it's the third version
of the software.
.html. And anyway, Anna, I'll put give
it back to you so you can get uh your
next speaker going. So, thanks everybody
for attending and have a great uh rest
of the week.
Thank you so much, Michael, for a great
presentation.
You're welcome. Thank you.
Let's move on and bring to the show our